if we sit around and and just kind of
complain for the next 6 months it could
be the end of the world but if we really
Pioneer new tech like hydrogen Tech and
really push it really push it we could
probably come out of this on top it
depends so if what we're facing right
now is actually a legitimate threat of
World War III the population decrease
from war and from the fact that people
don't have kids means what you're hoping
for is less likely to occur Tech
technological expansion typically
requires population expansion
like the the how many people does it
take to make one monitor screen it's it
probably like 500 different Specialties
to make one computer monitor but because
of the international economy and how
everything operates someone gets cobal
here and someone gets you know quartz
here and someone mines the the oil or
drills for the oil over here and then
they all go on these different
marketplaces I think a really good
example is probably just like pod taii